Hello, I’m Sam, this is my channel, this
is that Wikipedia list, and this… is That
Wikipedia List.
You can’t copy money.
I don’t mean it’s illegal, that’s obvious,
I mean that you physically cannot copy money
on a photocopier.
This is probably the only thing in the world
that your copier will just simply refuse to
copy.
With pretty much any modern copier, an error
message will come up if you put a banknote
or something resembling a banknote in the
scanner.
I’d tell you to try it, but there are so
many laws surrounding currency that I’m
pretty sure I’d have the police kicking
down my door tomorrow if I did.
You can just take my word for it.
It’s pretty interesting how money is detected
by photocopiers.
For almost any major currency, there’s one
symbol that tells machines that what they're
seeing is money.
It’s called the EURion constellation and
it looks like this.
It was first discovered on the 10 euro note
in this cluster of circles, but has since
been found on the American dollar, the Swedish
krona, the UK pound, and pretty much every
other major currency.
Most photocopiers will, if they see this pattern
of dots, stop printing in an attempt to stop
counterfeit.
At least, that’s how it used to be.
More recently, copiers have moved to a system
called the Counterfeit Deterrence System which
is incredibly secretive and effective.
Nobody is really sure how it works, and while
the Eurion constellation might be part of
it, these security measures make it even more
difficult to copy banknotes.
Adobe photoshop, like most photo editing softwares,
has the Counterfeit Deterrence System built
in which lets you see just how well it works.
Photoshop can of course detect this image
of a 10 pound note since it’s Eurion constellations
are clearly visable, but then it can also
detect it if the area is blacked out.
It can even figure out that this tiny almost
completely blacked out image is part of a
US $20 bill and refuse to edit it.
There’s almost no way to make counterfeiting
completely impossible, but the point of measures
against it is to make it so difficult that
the resources that would be used to counterfeit
money would be more expensive than the money
that could be made.
If it’s so difficult to make money that
it’s not profitable, nobody will do it.
There’s a ton of different laws relating
to the duplication and publication of visuals
of currency.
The US has 32 pages of laws related to currency.
Along with the obvious illegality of counterfeit,
it’s also illegal in the US to print or
publish any illustration of currency, postage
stamps, or revenue stamps of any nation in
the world unless, of course, it’s a stamp
made under the Migratory Bird Hunting Stamp
Act of 1934, and no, that’s not a joke.
It’s also illegal to deface currency in
any way or to use the image of currency in
any advertisement.
It is, however, legal to show authentic banknotes
in videos and films.
For this reason, in most cases, the money
used in movies is real.
To legally create prop money, the bill has
to be less than 75% or more than 150% of the
size of authentic currency, one sided, and
must be destroyed immediately after use.
Unless they want to do something that’s
illegal with money, like burn it or otherwise
deface it, filmmakers will often use real
money just for simplicity’s sake.
Some prop manufacturers will create a stack
of blank green paper then top it with one
real bill to give the appearance of stacks
of currency.
Also, one final law that you may not realize
related to currency is that private businesses
in the US have zero obligation to accept dollars
as payment.
Legally, they’re just as allowed to accept
galleons.
In conclusion, don’t mess around with counterfeit.
It will almost never end well.
Thank you for watching.
Sorry for the short episode, but I wanted
to get something out this week.
Right now I’m working on three or four videos
that I’m very excited about to be released
in the coming weeks and months so make sure
to click subscribe to catch those.
You can also follow me on Twitter @WendoverPro
for updates along the way.